(techno music)
- Welcome back to another
episode of the Addy Hour.
I'm grateful to be able to continue to
lead these conversations and discussions.
I think this is gonna be another great
discussion today as well.
Today, we're gonna be
focusing on the topic
of trauma and really digging
into the science of trauma.
And so I'm thrilled to be able to welcome
today's two guests.
I've been really eager to
have this joint conversation
with both of them and
extended conversation.
So I'm grateful that they've
been willing to jump in.
So our first guest is
Dr. Bianca Jones Marlin.
Dr. Bianca Jones Marlin
is an assistant professor
of psychology and of neuroscience
at Columbia Zuckerman Institute.
And I have to say, one
shocking thing about this today
is this is actually our
first time interacting.
And I say that's shocking
because I'm definitely
familiar with her work,
both her scientific work
and her outreach work in the community.
And I've heard her name for years
from lots of mutual
colleagues and mutual friends.
So I feel honored that we actually
have this time to finally interact.
I'm really grateful that she's been
willing to jump into the conversation.
But just to mention briefly,
Bianca has done stellar work
as a scientist throughout her career.
Even going back to graduate school
when she was focused on Oxytocin
and looking at its effects
on maternal behavior.
One of the other things
that I really appreciate
about Bianca is the work that
she's been doing recently,
really looking at these
trans-generational effects
and how experiences in one generation
can influence the brains
and the experiences
of subsequent generations and offspring.
So I know that's something we're also
gonna be talking about as well.
Also, deeply appreciative for the work
that she does around gender equity
and racial disparities within
the scientific community
and within community at large.
So grateful to have Bianca
on the program today with us.
Thanks for being here.
- Thank you for having me.
- Of course.
Our second guest is Dr. Kerry Ressler.
Dr. Ressler is a scientist and a physician
at McLean Hospital, and also
at Harvard Medical School.
He's a chair of psychiatry at McLean,
also the chief of the division of
depression and anxiety disorders,
and the chief scientific officer.
So just a few, a few titles there
obviously as someone who's deeply invested
in this area as well.
As I mentioned, he's a scientist
and a physician and has done a lot of work
really thinking about
the molecular processes
in the brain that are
important for emotion
and fear and anxiety,
but also does human genetic work as well.
And so, have been able to bridge
those two worlds very effectively.
And I have to say that one of the things
that I'm really deeply
appreciative with him is
I had the opportunity
to hear him give a talk
at a scientific conference years ago.
Hadn't met him yet, but that was really
deeply impressed by his
commitment to his work,
specifically the work that he was doing
in many marginalized
communities around aspects
and things like trauma and the effects of
just the experiences that
happen to those communities
and how these things can lead to
post-traumatic stress disorder.
He's been thinking about things like
susceptibility to substance
use and aspects of violence.
And for me, I was really just
to be honest, I was completely,
I don't want to say
enamored, but surprised
to see someone of your stature that was so
invested in the community.
And I know a lot of that was done through
the Grady project.
He was at Emory for 18 years
and was leading that project.
I'm sure we'll hear more about that today.
But just deeply grateful that you've been
doing this work for so long.
And I'm grateful that
both of you are wanting to
come on here together and
have this conversation
with one another.
So, welcome to the program, Dr. Ressler.
- Thanks so much Dr. Addy.
It's really a pleasure and really
looking forward to the conversation.
- And clearly this is
something that is a topic
of interest to us as a society.
I know that even in my own experiences
as I've been hosting different
events over the years
it's a phrase that comes up
much more frequently than in the past.
So people will talk
about, you know, the fact
that trauma can be passed
on at the molecular level.
That's something that I
think we can really unpack
in this conversation.
But even before we go there
I do like to often just
check in with guests
and see how you're both doing.
Obviously there's a lot that's happening
in our society right now.
We're in the middle of the Chauvin trial
and all the emotions that brings up.
We're continuing to deal with
all the racial injustices.
We're seeing the continuation and
upsurge of anti-Asian racism.
And so, I think it's a lot
for us to deal with and
I would just like to
see how people are doing
in the midst of everything
that's going on.
So Bianca, if you'd be willing to jump in
and start at that place.
- Yes, I am.
I think we're starting off with a very
heavy and loaded question.
I think we usually pass it.
We say like, "Oh, we're doing great."
I can't say I'm doing 100%
As you asked that question,
I pinched my fingers
so that I don't get too emotional.
It's a lot, it's very loaded right now.
I don't think that everyone
is always aware of that.
And so I think for some
of us who would affect
or maybe, I would hope that it
would affect everyone equally
but for those who seem
to feel a stronger pull
towards social injustice,
it is a little bit hard.
So it's been a rough
few days, I would say.
- Yeah.
Well, I definitely appreciate your honesty
in sharing that as well,
because I think that
that is part of what
we're trying to do here.
Not to just have that passive,
"Oh, everything's fine.
Everything's fine."
You know.
And there's a reason
that we go to that place.
I mean, there is a level
of vulnerability that comes
and we have to know
that people are actually
willing and ready to listen.
But here, I think it's so
important to just be honest.
And not to detour too
early in the conversation
but I think for many of us
who are in educational spaces
is that's important for our
students and trainees too
to not pretend that we're
doing better than we are
and to create the space
for them to be able to say,
"Okay, they're also struggling."
And that actually builds
the community as well.
So I appreciate you just-
(voices overlapping)
- Exactly, not just
(indistinct)
- Yeah. Yeah.
So important.
What about you, Kerry?
How are you?
How are you managing
with everything so far?
- Yeah, I think, you know,
it's been quite a year in so many ways
from all of the, you know I think from the
racial justice movements
and Black Lives Matter movement.
I think, for those of us who,
in many ways, those of
us in mental health,
I think are eternally optimistic.
(Kerry chuckles)
It feels like maybe this is the time.
It feels like, you know, since
at every step along the last 200 years
and certainly through the 60s
and Civil Rights Movements
and through the 70s, it can feel like,
"Okay, we're making progress now."
And hopefully we are, but
there's certainly many
many places of systemic racism and
institutionalized racism that we
haven't figured it out yet.
And I grew up in Mississippi.
And so I think we, as those of us who,
I think all of us have
different levels of privilege
but certainly, you know, very aware of
how I, and we as leadership
need to do better.
And so, I think it's such a call to action
and I just hope that we can really
make it matter in more, certain more
important ways this time.
So, thank you for hosting
this and for this conversation
'cause this is, I think,
a wonderful way to
explore these issues in
a much more deep way.
- Mm.
Yeah, I definitely appreciate that.
And I appreciate your acknowledgement
of the privilege that comes with that too.
In a way, you're saying both
privilege and responsibility.
So not just privilege
- Absolutely.
- But to actually take
steps to move forward.
And at the same time, it
sounds like you're trying to be
I mean, in a lot of ways,
you're both being realistic.
There are aspects of pain.
That's real.
We can't avoid that.
There are aspects of optimism but
there are also aspects of
we've done this before and
let's not get stuck in that same cycle
of just kind of repeating the lip service
and just going back to
the way things were.
So I think that's so important.
And I appreciate your
acknowledgement of what we're
trying to do with this podcast as well
to make sure that we can really talk about
the things that aren't
always talked about.
Just kind of get,
I don't want to say
buried under the surface,
but get left kind of, in that space of,
'well, we don't really
want to touch that.'
And Bianca, I know
you've done a lot of that
over the last year as well.
Kerry, I know through our interactions
that's been the focus for you.
So again, I'm just grateful,
grateful to both of you
for the way that you're pulling
all those things together.
It's not easy, not easy
in any sense of the word.
So Kerry, you hinted a little
bit about your background.
I did wanna dig in a
little bit deeper there
and actually ask both of you
how you got to this place in your lives of
being deeply invested
in neuroscience research
especially for those in our
audience who aren't scientists.
I'm sure they'd be curious to hear
why are the two of you so
deeply invested in this area?
So Kerry, if you could
talk a little bit about
your journey, I guess both to medicine
and to neuroscience research.
How did you come to that place?
- Sure.
For a brief background.
So I grew up in Mississippi
for multiple generations in the South
and first generation college
from a single parent household.
So although I was white, my mom grew up in
segregationist Mississippi
and her best friends
were black, where she
lived in the country.
And so I really heard the
stories of what that was like.
So I was always very aware, you know
had a very progressive mother
in early 70s Mississippi.
And so was very aware of
racial injustice from there.
So that side, and then I was also
working in a grocery store and
everything else to just get by.
And fortunately, had great math teachers
and great teachers and had
the opportunity to do well.
And I was sort of a child of
the first generation of computers.
So I was applying for college
and my math teacher said,
"You should look at MIT"
and I'm like, "What is MIT?"
(laughs)
And so I was fortunate
enough to get into MIT
and I went there to be
a computer scientist
as I thought.
I'm still convinced that I got into MIT
because I was the token Mississippi person
but I'll take it.
(laughs)
But along the way,
I was already exposed for the first time
to molecular biology neuroscience
and just absolutely fell in love with it.
In the 80s, seeing this sort of
molecular generate revolution
that you can really engineer biology
seemed much more exciting to me
than engineering program computers.
So, long story short.
Did that.
Was in on the fence between
neuroscience and medicine.
I worked in emergency departments
and worked in medicine.
Just really wanted to
give back to the community
but loved research.
So I was fortunate enough to get into
an MD-PhD program and
stay in Boston at Harvard.
And that's where I met Linda Buck.
I was doing research.
I was doing my rotations
for what I was going to do my PhD in
and couldn't quite find the right one.
I wanted to do plasticity
and learning and memory.
And there weren't many people
at Harvard at the time.
And then somebody said,
"You should come hear this
job talk by this Buck person."
And so I went, not knowing
anything about smell in my life
and Linda Buck and Richard Axel
who you'll hear from
Bianca, had just discovered
the odor receptor gene family.
And that just opened my
eyes to a whole way that one
could use molecular tools to
understand a sensory system.
And it really, for the
last 30 years since then
been using molecular tools to understand
systems' neuroscience questions.
And as we get into the
later discussion about
some of the intergenerational stuff,
it was that background in olfaction
that was really exciting.
So, from there did a
post-doc at Emory in Atlanta
and moved to Atlanta
for a number of reasons.
It's a great program.
My wife was from there and we had a baby.
All those things.
And Grady Hospital, one of the main
teaching hospitals in a way, and
I really wanted to give
back and train at Grady.
And so, while both working
with Michael Davis there
on fear, and he was one of the founders
of the amygdala systems,
I started using molecular
biology approaches
to understanding the amygdala and fear.
Also was approached
began to understand what PTSD was
in the veterans' populations.
And in my work as a psychiatrist at Grady
really saw that trauma was everywhere
and yet we weren't paying attention to it.
And so that really began
our 20-year journey
into understanding
trauma in the inner city.
And since then, we've
interviewed almost 13,000 people
coming to Grady hospital
just for general medical care
in that process and learned a lot about
trauma exposure, just the enormity of it.
The enormity of PTSD and
depression and co-morbidity.
So really, I've spent a lot of my years
in trying to understand
by understanding the medical model
and neuroscience approach to trauma
and that really helps us have
better interventions and improvements.
So that's me.
Otherwise, I've been married for 30 years.
I have a couple dogs and three boys.
(Addy chuckles)
and I'm very grateful
for the life I've had.
Thank you.
- That's great.
Well, thanks for sharing the journey.
I mean, even going all the
way back to the beginning.
That was very impressive by the way,
the way you succinctly encapsulate
so many aspects of your life story.
But I appreciate that.
I think it's helpful for people to be able
to just get the the entire context too.
I mean, even going back
to your family history
and your first-generation experiences
and the opportunities that
you're able to take advantage of.
Definitely appreciate that.
I know we'll tie back and
think even more deeply
about some of the work
that you're currently
doing now as well.
But just grateful for the
investment that you've made
in a lot of ways.
- Thank you.
- And Bianca, what about you?
I know you shared some of your story
in other settings before, both in terms of
your scientific journey
and your family background
growing up, and your
thoughts about teaching
how all that led you to this place.
So curious to have you expand
on that a little bit here as well.
- Yes, I'm so happy to expand.
I'm a little bit overwhelmed at the
amazing parallel between Kerry and myself.
I don't think, just
taking a brief look at us.
I mean, if there's anything
that's similar outside of
we're both gray hair color-wise, but
I'm so taken aback.
And so thank you so much for sharing,
especially like some
aspects that I have found
as I continue on in science that
are sometimes hard to share openly
like struggles coming
from a single family home
coming from like, maybe a low SES.
I've been very hesitant
to share these things.
Just only as of recently
that I realized that
in me sharing this, I'm
inspiring people who
don't know that they
assume differently about me
that like, "Oh, they
can actually do this."
It's possible.
Not hard, but possible.
So I am a New Yorker, through and through.
Born and raised.
Very proud of that.
So I can't pronounce words like drawer.
It's totally fine.
We say it too often in science
and everyone's always confused.
It's fine.
So, I'm from New York, born in Queens
and I'm first generation
American on one side.
My mother was born in
Guyana, South America.
My dad is a New Yorker,
through and through
for a few generations.
Although I do have family from my
outside of Birmingham,
my grandmother was born
right outside of Birmingham.
So, one side is black American,
and the other side is Guyanese.
And,
I, from my perspective
I had an extremely happy
and amazing childhood.
And I do think that
it's only in retrospect
that I realized how
uniquely set up my childhood
was in inspiring what I do now.
So I grew up in a,
my parents, my biological parents
but they were foster parents as well.
So I have foster siblings
and adopted siblings
which allowed me insight
into other people's
world and life, without
ever, like I'm so thankful
without ever having to experience it
because a lot of these things
are associated with trauma.
If you are in the foster care system,
it's because you have a
caregiver who wasn't able to
live up to that definition of caregiver
and in no shame associated
with the caregiver.
And I feel that very strongly.
That's also why I study parental behavior
because we can't always say it's like
the parent's issue or the child's issue.
There's a lot of things
involved with that.
But I was able to get
a little bit of insight
into how it is to live in a
home that wasn't like mine.
And I think that really motivated
me to go into education.
So I first started off as a teacher.
It's amazing, like Kerry said.
Someone said, "Go check out MIT."
And you're like, "What is MIT?"
I started going into
education and I saw a sign
that said like, do one, in college.
I went to St. John's in Queens.
I literally have never
I haven't left New York
(Bianca chuckles)
My undergrad, grad school,
postdoc is all here.
And I saw a flyer that said
you can go to get free tuition.
You work in a lab.
I was like, "That sounds great."
I was an education major.
And I started doing fungal genetics
and it entered me into
the world of science.
They ask what does a PhD stand for?
And I was like,
(mumbles)
I didn't know what to say before,
and I learned more about PhD.
Presenting that data at a
conference called ABRCMS
It's the annual biomedical
research conference
for minority students.
I had someone come up to me, a Dean
and he's like, "Oh, you
should check out my school,
MIT, for our summer program.
Being from New York, I know MIT.
I know NYIT, New York
Institute of Technology
which like a little school in my town.
And I was like, "I guess if
I wanna go to Massachusetts.
Sure, I'll check it out."
(Bianca chuckles)
It was that same year
that a movie came out
called '21', which is about some brilliant
MIT's mathematicians,
who go to Vegas and they game the system
and win a whole lot of money.
And I was like-
- I knew some of the people in that group.
- Did you?
(laughs)
- Wow.
- Sorry, go on.
- MIT's a big deal!
Oh! I should fill up an application out.
I did not know at all.
- Oh my goodness.
- So that was one of my
ways into neuroscience.
I worked in a lab there for the summer.
I learned more about neuroscience.
And I think during that, the path of
being part of this program which is for
first generation student, college students
which I was, the first of my family to go
to college and graduate.
First generation Americans, low SES
all the things I checked off.
The program that got
me, that introduced me
to this research, really
allowed me to align
the fact that I loved teaching.
I loved the concept of learning.
I wanted to understand
how environmental factors
like stress, like
trauma, made it different
for my siblings to navigate school.
And for me, I was a pretty
solid, straight A student.
I knew my siblings had the
capabilities to do that
but I just think
environmental factors did not
allow them to focus on that
'cause there was so much more going on.
And so, within getting
the science component,
the learning and then being
introduced to neuroscience,
the summer programs that I went to,
I decided I wanted to
study learning and memory
as opposed to being a teacher.
I did teach 7th grade,
10th grade and AP biology
for a year before I
entered into grad school.
For any graduate students listening,
I had a very interesting
graduate school career.
I did five rotations.
Most people do three, in a lab,
to find where you wanna go.
And the fifth rotation
was with Robert Froemke.
Dr. Robert Froemke.
And he was like, "You can
do some of this stuff.
Some of this stuff.
I have a slight interest
in maternal behavior."
And I was like, "Oh, that's me.
That's what I wanna do.
I wanna study maternal behavior."
And it led to the Oxytocin Project that
a large percentage of his
lab is now looking at.
And similarly, when it came
to looking into my postdoc
I had a few offers.
My PhD work was very well received
and we found some pretty
amazing groundbreaking results
that led me to offers to start my own lab
prior to even doing a postdoc.
And so I looked into those.
But on meeting Richard Axel
who I'm honored doing my post-doc with,
who is also here at Columbia,
who won the Nobel prize with Linda Buck,
who Kerry worked with.
He, A, convinced me that New
York is where I wanted to stay.
He's really good at that.
He's also a New Yorker.
And B, that I can learn a new facet.
I also didn't think I would
be interested in odor.
My former work was auditory.
So listening.
It's a beautiful stimulus.
You play a tone, you see
a response in the brain,
like humidity doesn't change it.
You can wear perfume.
Odor is very different.
But the questions you can
ask with a beautiful system
like the olfactory system,
just opened my mind to
and my eyes to so many aspects.
And the fact that we can associate trauma
and memory with things like
what grandma was cooking in the kitchen
and the smell of the apple pie.
It excites me as to where
we can take this field.
And so now, I'm an assistant
professor at Columbia
studying how trauma is passed down
through generations and
how parents play a role
in this and how environmental
factors like smell
and sound and taste and the senses
take in the world and
keep those memories in
and pass those memories on.
- Wow.
That's so
inspiring and humbling, at the same time,
to hear you share your story.
And I'm struck.
I mean, you said this yourself, right?
How many intersections and
overlaps you and Kerry have.
Even the interjection about the MIT folks.
(Bianca laughs)
I mean, there's just, wow.
So scientifically and otherwise.
And I think, I mean, that's the beauty of
the work we do sometimes, I think too.
And to be honest, I think it also speaks
to the importance of sometimes
us having conversations
outside of our specific scientific
question and discipline,
not that there's anything wrong with that.
I mean, we all get
really excited about that
but there's so much more.
Sometimes, I think that we don't have
the chance to appreciate
because we are stuck
in that kind of framework about
only speaking about things in one way.
So, obviously that's a
maybe that's a self-serving comment
'cause that's one of the things
that I'm really trying to do
on the Addy Hour too,
just to be able to pull in
so many different topics and make sure
that we can unearth all
those pieces as well.
So, definitely appreciate you Bianca,
sharing those components,
and Kerry as well.
There's so many different
directions that we could go.
I mean, to be honest, it's almost feels
like it could be a
three hour conversation.
- Yeah, it does.
- We're not gonna do that, but
(Addy chuckles)
But one thing that I did want to pull out
from something you both
mentioned too, is just
how you got interested,
and Bianca, you touched
on this already too.
But about trauma specifically,
just because clearly
that's something that has
a lot of societal implications.
I think in a lot of ways in the last year,
as a broader society
both of you have been
thinking about this already
but we're starting to
pay much more attention
to that than we have in the past.
So, I'm curious to hear
even a little bit more
about how you got invested in that.
And then if you could
also just unpack this idea
of the cellular molecular ways
that trauma gets passed on.
What does that actually mean?
Because of that phrase, as I mentioned
gets thrown around a lot.
And I think it's good that people
are paying attention to it.
But I think it's also important
that we really have a good understanding.
And to be honest, that's an illness
that I think we as scientists
have to communicate that.
So Kerry, if we can go
ahead and start with you.
- So as you say, we could probably talk
for 10 hours on those two topics.
I'll give the very short version
and we can dive deeper.
(Kerry chuckles)
So for me,
I was interested in
trauma as a psychiatrist
who wanted to combine
so it really, two sides.
One, the intellectual side.
I found that our
understanding in the late 90s
of the amygdala and the
brain circuit regions
that encode the fear and threat responses
were some of the best
understood brain circuits
that we had in mammals.
And so as a physician scientist,
I really wanted to study something
that I could both understand
more mechanistically
in an animal system and understand
in something relevant to humans.
So I was very attracted to PTSD
as a purely intellectual question.
But I also really, you
know, I went into medicine
and wanted to do something
related to helping people
but from both my Mississippi
and earlier backgrounds
and seeing racial injustice,
I really wanted to
do something that could
eventually help the community.
I knew I wasn't gonna be a policy wonk.
It wasn't really who I was,
but if I could do something scientifically
that would speak to community issues
that would be a lovely
way to combine them.
And for me, it started
when my eyes were opened up
working at Grady as an intern
in the first year of residency
and was interviewing people in our general
So Grady hospitals,
the main receiving area
the main trauma hospital for all of
Atlanta's five plus million people.
And they're also the main
psychiatric receiving facility.
And, you'd be thrown in
there as an early resident
not really knowing much of anything
'cause you interview
people and make decisions.
And what I found first is that nobody
quite fit our different
diagnostic criteria.
Everybody, you know,
there was substance abuse
there was depression,
there was suicidality
there was psychosis and all
of it was kinda mixed up.
And certainly substance
was underlying a lot of it.
But having come from the VA and
seeing the PTSD in the veterans,
to me, it was very obvious.
As soon as we started
asking people about trauma,
it was everywhere, and it
was almost like in the 1800s
we called syphilis kind
of the great mimicker.
And I think trauma's kind
of a great mimicker for it
whether they're medical comorbidities
or psychiatric comorbidities
or other components.
So I just, I was fascinated with it.
And so for me, being
able to look at trauma
from both the basic side, understand PTSD
and start to really help
understand and give voice to
civilian trauma and in at-risk communities
and how that also speaks
to the cycle of violence
and the cycle of risk, were all
fascinating to me in humans.
So, maybe I'll pause there and then we can
maybe do a second round
when we start talking
about the details of the
intergenerational work.
- Yeah, that sounds great.
Thanks for just sharing
that context as well.
I think that's really
helpful for people to
know what motivated you.
And it's inspiring again,
to hear that you are
paying attention to what
you saw in front of you.
I think that's something that comes
up in a lot of our conversations, too.
Especially as we go
through the mental health
whether the providers are
basically putting their categories
onto people or listening
to people's stories.
And it sounds like in a lot of ways
you were watching and
listening to the stories
and the experiences that
you saw in front of you
and saying, "Okay, what
is that leading me to?"
Rather than the other way around.
I think that's a really important-
- Yeah, just to interject,
to follow that up.
The number of people that
we would see with diagnosis
there's certainly plenty
with schizophrenia
and bipolar and severe depression
but there's a lot of folks
with very severe trauma
and underlying PTSD that I
think are either misdiagnosed
or they're putting their
priorities in the wrong place.
- Yeah, yeah.
Really important.
And again, a whole other conversation,
which we may pull in later,
but even the disparities that come along
that as well, even terms
of racial disparities-
- And that black people
are much more likely to be
diagnosed with severe mental illness
than identifying their underlying trauma.
- Yeah.
So Bianca, to pivot back to you
we've pulled out a lot,
but you shared some of that already from
your childhood experiences too
but were there other
components that pulled you
into this work or things that
are kind of ongoing for you?
- I think we as scientists,
we walk the line
between what did the data say
and what do we know as humans?
Like, what do we intuit?
And the data, we're
still parsing this out.
We're still ironing out
what mechanisms could be.
And that's okay, right?
Like I need to have a job.
So I'm fine with that.
We don't have all the answers yet
but we know as humans.
When we think about finding a partner
a lot of people ask like,
"What kind of family do they come from?"
"What have they gone through?"
"What are their parents like?"
We know that certain elements
are imprinted into people.
We know that people who
have gone through war
we just intuit that,
potentially there can be
something that lingers.
I was in a military family.
My brother serves in the
United States military.
Navy.
And there's certain elements when he was
out and he came back,
but we would wanna ask
to see how he was feeling.
I didn't need data to
know that if you came
from an abusive household, you were
sexually or physically
or emotionally abused,
that that has ramifications.
I didn't need to look at
your epigenetic changes
because we know these things as humans.
And so I think that, in understanding
that we get this as humans,
I'm confident that as we get this,
the data will come rolling.
And so I think that's
what I try to go back to
when stuff is hard in the lab and
you can't really put our finger on
what it is that we're looking for.
I just look at society.
We know these things as human beings.
And so there's gotta be
an underlying written
script there for the
behavioral offsets that we see.
- Yeah, I think that's really
important in so many ways.
And you're right.
That line, I'm glad that you brought it up
because I think we,
sometimes we walk that line
without acknowledging
that we walked that line.
I imagine that for both of you,
that might be something
that's talked about
more often than in other circles
but I think it's a principle
that a lot of us should be
thinking about more explicitly as well.
And I, even the pieces that you pulled out
about how to really think
about the data versus
what we know inherently in
front of us is really important.
I'm curious if you could expand
a little bit on this idea
of who's, what's often
characterized as who's at fault
because you hinted that too.
'cause you hinted at the
fact that if you know
your brother's coming back
from a difficult situation
you all have some grace
in how you're thinking
about what experiences he had.
But I think a lot of
times, when we're talking
about underserved communities,
there's this narrative
that gets framed that
while you also just pull yourselves up
by your bootstraps.
You know, putting the fault
on the victims in a sense.
I'm just curious how you think about that
both in terms of society-wise
and in terms of your research.
Bianca, if you wanna just
expand on that a little bit.
- Of course, yes.
That's a very important question.
And I fully support pulling yourself
up from your bootstraps.
If you have boots.
And I think that's the issue.
When I speak about, or when I think about
my experience growing up
with my foster siblings
and I want to make sure
I'm very clear,
I'm not speaking from
them or their perspective.
I'm speaking as myself who had
two loving, caring parents
and the things I learned from them.
I don't ever want to be their voice
but I do want to share
my experience with them.
They came from abusive households
where their parents
tried the best they could
to manage their children
under the stressors
they were, stressors they had
after coming from abusive households.
And so it's not as if like,
this just magically
erupted in their lineage.
This is generation upon generation
upon generation, of suppression, of abuse,
of substance abuse.
But these aren't things
that we can just target
to one person because,
and I, for all I know
some of the people who came
from these households,
who became my siblings
could also then have children
and have to grapple with the way
that they parent their
kids and what they learned.
And we see this aligned
in a lot of our research.
There is a rodent
research that's shown that
if you have a mother who
smells like peppermint
and then you have her offspring
and you shock her offspring
while she's next to the
mom with peppermint.
Even though the animals felt shock,
so it felt pain surrounding the mom,
it still prefers peppermint.
And so there's something
innate about saying,
"Although I know that this
is not a good situation.
I do wanna go back to this parent.
I do wanna go back to my mother."
And how much of that can
be parsed out societally
by saying, "Your mother was horrible.
You cannot be like this person.
Your father was horrible.
You cannot be like this person."
And having the pull to love.
And so I do find that's something that I
it's hard to parse out in the science
because you want something clean, crisp
like the data say this.
But there are emotions
involved with parenthood.
There are emotions involved
with generations to come.
And what that looks like in rodents
which is what I use to study in my
look at my question,
it's hard to not to anthropomorphize that.
- Yeah, that's a really good example.
Go ahead, Kerry.
- Sorry, that was
beautifully said, Bianca.
You know, it's kind of
we're bringing it back to the big story.
And I really see that
that's so much an issue
with institutional racism.
I think you can even
have people meaning well
(indistinct)
they don't understand, we don't understand
because there's just so
many false equivalencies.
Doesn't matter what happened
to you when you're early
we're now giving you school opportunity.
We're giving you some food.
We're giving a headstart.
We're giving a job.
Why aren't things better?
And there's just a lack of appreciation
that these things that
we know are critical
for our developmental, like you said,
but even with the topic of this,
potentially even intergenerational
that we've got to be more
you can't just have a headstart program.
You can't just have a job opportunity.
If the emotional building
blocks aren't there
in addition to the new opportunities,
it's not gonna work.
So, you don't have the boots
even though it may look
like you have them.
So there's that.
Due to false equivalencies of,
"Okay we're giving them now"
but they're just not the same.
And we haven't, as a society,
learned that or figured
out what to do about that.
- Yeah, I think that's so important.
And I appreciate the fact that you're
pulling that out too,
Both of you, that we have
we can see those society-wise as well.
We don't have to wait for all the data
to know that that's true.
But even at the same time, Kerry.
If you could just expand on what the data
has started to show us about
how those processes are actually happening
in terms of what Bianca
already brought up.
- Sure, so one of the things,
sort of two brief stories
that we've been most excited about
is this concept of epigenetics.
I think most people are familiar
with the idea of genetics.
That's what you're born with, your DNA,
it's in your cells.
And, you know, essentially
we all come from
a mix of our moms' and our dads' genes.
But over the last couple decades,
it's really understood that there's
this concept of epigenetics.
How the genes can be altered.
And data, for a number of years
have suggested that developmental trauma
be that neglect, abuse, physical,
sexual, emotional abuse
that's more associated with
all bad things basically
Whether it'd be medical, psychological,
substance abuse, risk, et cetera.
And we're starting to understand that
marks, both in your blood and in the brain
the ways in which the
genes have been altered
via this early developmental experience
through this epigenetic term.
And so that's one way
that we're starting to
understand how the biology
of development may hold
on and be kind of stuck
there during adulthood.
And one, for example,
that we've been involved
with a lot is a gene that's involved
in the stress regulatory system
and epigenetic changes
in some of these genes
alter how the body and the
mind respond to stress.
And that looks very different
if you've had childhood trauma versus not
and likely very much
tunes the stress system
and the body and the brain
very differently in adulthood.
And then the work where Bianca and I met
and share scientific excitement is
we both start in the olfactory system
I'd been working for a few years
and then had transitioned over to
studying fear and amygdala.
But for all the reasons Bianca said,
the olfactory system is so fascinating
and one of which is
because we can structure
we have molecular tools that allow us to
see the structural
organization of how smell works
in the nose and in the brain.
The part of the brain
called the olfactory bowl.
And we found, based on really inspired by
work by many scientists over decades,
where they showed that if
you had early experiences,
it changed the structure of the brain
and you had different sensory systems.
And we were able to show that
if you even had an adult,
because of the, what we know now is
if there's turnover constantly
in the olfactory system.
That's why if somebody
has a cold or COVID now
and loses smell, eventually it comes back
because the cells grow back.
So that suggested there's
this ongoing plasticity
in the olfactory system
that may be different
than other sensory systems.
And so we found that if you
train an animal to be afraid of
so you can shock them with a cherry smell
that the sense specific
molecular markers of cherry
actually increase in the nose
and increase in the brain.
So you have an increased representation
and an increased behavioral
sensitization of that cherry
and the molecular mechanisms
that are starting to be understood.
And a brilliant postdoc
named Brian Dias in the lab
wanted to look at this in broader ways
and basically almost randomly
he planned it.
I wasn't very surprised
and have found that
if you train, if you shock
basically traumatize a father
before they give birth
to this cherry smell
the offspring actually are
more sensitive to cherry
have more representation
of cherry in the nose
and more representation
of cherry in the brain.
And he showed that in
lots of different ways
that even if you just take the sperm
of the father after
they've been traumatized
and do what we call
in-vitro fertilization,
take it to a different place,
no behavioral interaction at all
the next generation
still had these molecular
and structural and behavioral marks
of increased sensitization
to this trauma smell
suggesting that at least
one sensory system,
the olfactory system, is able to hold onto
somehow some of its olfactory information
that is important across generations.
And that has so many implications
that we can talk about.
So my way of getting to know Bianca
was I heard these rumors
that there was somebody
from the Axel lab who'd
replicated some of the work
and we all got very excited
the next thing you know.
A year and a half, be anxiously awaiting
to meet her to hear more about it.
- Yeah.
I mean, that speaks to the
scientific endeavor too.
And I'm curious actually,
to even piggyback on that and see
just to hear from both from your pers-
How did people first respond to the work?
(Kerry chuckles)
- I'll let Kerry answer that
'cause I heard that in parallel
as I was making a decision
as to what I was going to
focus my postdoctoral work on
and my postdoctoral advisor was like,
"Are you sure you wanna study
this? Because I know that-
(voices overlapping)
Run away!
(laughs)
But it goes back to what I was saying.
We know these things intuitively as humans
but it's so hard to convince people that
the data of what we're
showing is relevant.
So I'll let Kerry answer
that question because I'm-
- Yeah, I mean the brief
answer is skepticism.
Lots and lots of skepticism.
There's, you know, other work by people
like Isabelle Mansuy and Tracy Bale
in Germany and Maryland
who'd done other great work
concerning intergenerational stress.
Problem is, the stress
system's really complicated
and it's kind of nuanced
and there's not really very
specific molecules all the time.
And I think what's the olfactory
system has going for us
and why this story from all
of our groups is so powerful
is that we do have these
very precise markers.
And you can, you have
these molecular markers
for one smell versus another smell.
So you have this built-in
control to show that
you can have this inheritance that
affects one smell system but not the
so it's one odor, but not another.
And that allowed us to overcome it.
But all the skepticism certainly
made the paper better
and made us do a lot more
of the gazillion extra experiments
to really show that this
is a real phenomenon.
We don't know what it means
but we know it's in the sperm
and we think it's epigenetics.
But one kind of fun example is,
so this comes back to
this historical thing
of Darwin versus Lamarck.
What are you inherit
versus what can you change.
And everybody was saying,
"Oh, this is Lamarck."
And so we threw that out.
The problem is we didn't know about
epigenetics and we didn't know
that probably both are true at some level.
And we were trying not to
so we were trying to avoid that issue
and just talk about the data
and then nature neuroscience word came out
without telling us, putting
Lamarck on the cover.
(laughs)
We're trying to avoid that issue.
- Yeah, no choice.
(laughs)
That's how it works sometimes.
Yeah, that's really helpful.
I think to know that obviously
it wasn't easy at the time
but to know the context
too, and the pushback.
How would you say, and maybe Bianca
you can talk about this.
Was that mirrored on the societal side?
Like how the society as a collective
respond to the work?
- I think that comes back
to our job as scientists
by taking the data and saying that
these are the data that we have.
We're in the process of interpreting them.
And I think that comes back to,
I don't think I would say I know this
comes back to the fact that
if I'm flipping through a paper
or I'm flipping through a book
or I'm not a scientist.
I'm just reading the New York Times
or something of the sort
and I see, "You've had trauma in your past
and now you're ruined for life
because these epigenetic markers have
now been ingrained in your system."
And so you're just like,
you're out of luck.
I would be pretty offended
and I'd be angered
because this person,
this scientist doesn't know who I am.
They don't know how I deal with things.
I think that's a part that we
need to definitely highlight.
We don't know exactly
what we're looking at.
We could be looking at
something that could align
with PTSD, increased sensitivity
to a non-threatening cue.
We could be looking at resilience,
the ability of the nose
to then sense an odor
that in the past was traumatizing.
But now, I'm warned about it earlier
because I have more neurons
that are going to say, hmm,
or learn more quickly.
And so the data remained the same
but those two explanations
are how we interpret the data.
My goal as a scientist is to
take the data that we have
and really interpret it
and with multiple facets
in the way that benefits society.
And so I'm very hesitant
when we speak about trauma,
just trauma, trauma
because that can be really traumatizing
especially for someone like me
who's like a black woman,
first generation SES.
I don't wanna just swallow
the fact that like,
okay, I have generations upon generations
of slavery-induced trauma.
And now I just can't
live life functionally.
Maybe there's an element of resilience
that can be inherited as well.
And just remembering that, I think
gives me energy and
joy, and I do wanna tell
I try to make sure that the community
and society at large knows,
these are just the data.
It could mean something bad.
It could mean something amazing.
And we're in the process
of figuring that out.
- Yeah.
That's so good-
- Can I just add to that too?
I think it was so beautifully said.
You know, one of the
things I wanna make sure
that I get in and I always try to
when I talk about this is the latest work
that I think is so exciting is that
if you take the same fathers,
you traumatized them to the cherry,
but then you extinguish them.
You essentially give them exposure therapy
just like we do with PTSD.
And then you make them
offspring looked just
like nothing ever happened.
So what this suggests is that
all of these processes are plastic.
And if we know the right way to intervene
in the way to help
further build resilience
that these are plastic, they're not fate.
And that's, I think really important.
- Yeah, really important points.
And beautiful segue too because
one of the things that often we try
and talk about on the Addy hour.
So me, as a basic neuroscientist,
obviously like you
I'm very focused on the
processes in the brain
that are contributing to these challenges
and to also to resilience as well.
But then I also try hard not
to talk about these things
only in a bubble.
So I'm thinking about
all the other components
that contribute to emotional wellness
and to mental health challenges
and to come in through those
mental health challenges.
So thinking about spiritual
components, you know
the social justice, racism,
all the different interventions we have,
whether that be
psychological interventions,
prayer and meditation,
and how all of these things impinge.
So I think it's always good for us to have
as you both mentioned that focus,
but I'm curious
well you've both talked about this already
and Kerry, even with that last data.
How do you see all those different
types of processes being important
in terms of how we think about
mental health in general?
Both from what you've seen in your data
and from a broader societal perspective.
I realize that's a huge question
but I'd love to hear your
thoughts on both of those.
Bianca, if you wanna start.
- Yes, I
I want,
I shouldn't say 'I want'
'cause they're following the data.
And what I believe is that
biology has a setup for success
not for failure.
And any aspects that we're inheriting
or any epigenetic component
really in the proper framework
is for us to succeed in that environment.
Not to fail.
Like evolution doesn't want
us to just crash and burn
because it doesn't have a job.
Like we talked about having a job.
You can always tell, in 10 years
when it's like, "the job"
(laughs)
If you need the job.
Yeah, and so with that being said,
I think that's the case.
Like biology will always look out for us.
That our brains and our bodies
and those adaptations that it goes through
will always look out for us.
And so if we have the inkling to rest,
we probably need to do that.
We have the inkling,
whatever that rest looks like
to you to pray, to take a second, to read,
to hang out with your
whatever that inkling is,
I suggest following that.
And that's what I do in my life,
because I trust my body's saying
because humans haven't
been around for this long
and we haven't knocked
ourselves off the planet yet.
And so it's
there's gotta be something there
I should be listening to.
- Hmm.
That's so well said.
And still a lot to unpack as well.
- Yes
- Yeah, in terms of how all that
impacts our brains and moves us forward.
What about you, Kerry?
- Yeah, I agree with all of that.
I think, you know, to
anthropomorphize a bit
but try to understand that
reason why this might happen.
We think about if a
mouse grew up in one part
from parent, you know
they might have enough
smell systems to be able to
smell 10,000 different odors,
but there may only be 50
or a hundred that really matter
for the last couple of generations
where the parents lived
for both where the food were
and where the prey was.
And if you could be predisposed
to be more sensitive to those,
that would be really good, you know?
So we don't know what
exactly that means in humans.
And I think everything
you said is right on.
I think for how I think about
some of these things as a psychiatrist
is that it reminds me that,
one of the take-home tenants of psychiatry
is that our emotional
responses are not always
what we think they are.
(Kerry chuckles)
And they're not always
what we consciously want.
They're what our brain,
because of our DNA,
our epigenetics and our
lifetime experiences
emotionally have us respond to.
And sometimes that's
really helpful, that gut.
And other times, it can
keep getting us stuck
in a rut of behaviors
that we may not want.
And I think this is one more place where
as we continue to learn more
about the human conditioning,
learn how we can all help
ourselves and help each other
it's figuring out what
things are we responding to
because that's where we are in the present
and that's what we want
which is when we are
responding to the past
and maybe we don't know it.
- Yeah, so well said as well.
There's so many, so many topics
that you all are pulling out.
I know we're running close
to the end of our time.
May have to have both of
you back at some point.
One thing that I did
want to mention though
that we didn't talk about as much
but it's just a theme
of community as well.
So Bianca, I know that's
something that's come
through your work in a lot of ways.
And Kerry, as you were talking,
I sense that that's there as well
even in terms of what you've
done in the Grady Project.
And one of the things that I often
that we've talked about on this podcast,
and we'll probably talk
about more in the future
is just the effects of community.
So we're talking about
a lot of the effects
of trauma on the brain,
but the effects of community on the brain.
I mean, that ties back again
to some of the Oxytocin work.
I'll probably try and have Larry Young
on at some point as well.
I haven't told him that yet.
So maybe he'll hear that through this.
But I think just the importance
of that community component
and how that intersects on so many levels
with the processes in the brain
that you've both been studying for years.
And then some of these just inherent,
gut feelings that we have
as human beings as we interact.
I mean, we do, again as a neuroscientist
I like to focus on the brain
but some days we can really
just feel in ourselves
even as we've lost some of that
with all those Zoom conversations.
Also, I did want to mention
that and just say that
I think that's another key component.
And getting back to what Bianca said about
the biology is there to
protect us, in a way.
And some of that I think
is through community.
And obviously there's a lot of research
that backs that up as well.
But then again, there's so much
I feel like this conversation
could've gone for many, many more hours.
Definitely-
- I think there's lots of data that
for your next topic, you know,
- Yeah, exactly.
- Both in Bianca and Larry Young
and chime in on others' work on Oxytocin
in community and then work by many
including some of our work
showing that community cohesion
buffers childhood trauma on the effects
of adult PTSD and that one of the biggest
supporting factors that matters
no matter how bad your life is
if you have one or two strong adults
who are there, supporting you and
you have that support system,
that can buffer so much difficulty.
And so, whether that's through church
whether that's through the local Y,
whether it's through the coach
or whatever, that community is so critical
for survival and for
resilience and being strong.
- Yeah.
So important.
- The greater brain that
worked is community.
We have our brains connected
to different neurons
but we don't live
individually, we as humans.
Like Oxytocin's there and it's
a bigger global brain I think
that we can't forget about.
- Yeah.
Well, you're both leaving
me hungry for more.
I imagine that our listeners
are feeling the same way.
Yeah, so if you'd both be willing,
I definitely would love to have you back
and continue this conversation.
Again, just really grateful to both of you
for being willing to jump on
early in this Addy hour
initiative that we're
getting off the ground here.
I think that these
conversations have been great
and there's so much, I
think that's gonna really
be important for our listeners
and things that people
can really grab onto.
So, I appreciate both of you.
Both Dr. Bianca Jones Marlin and
Dr. Kerry Ressler for jumping
on the Addy Hour today.
This has been just,
yeah, I know I'm gonna be
I'm already still thinking through
everything that you've brought up.
There's so much more to chew on,
but grateful for the chance
for both you to be here
and contribute this way.
- Thank you.
Thank you so much for
inviting and having me.
I really appreciate it.
- Thanks so much Nii,
and, Bianca great to see you.
Really fun conversation.
- Yeah, it's been a pleasure.
(techno music)